[Musique]
alors bonjour à tous merci d'être là
aujourd'hui et aujourd'hui on va parler
de blog shane cette technologie dont
tout le monde parle mais que personne ne
comprend alors très simplement je vais
vous parler de quatre concepts et des
liens qui régissent entre elles qui sont
la compréhension la confiance la
puissance et la responsabilité
si vous retenez un de ces concepts et un
de ces liens moi j'ai réussi ma
présentation
si vous retenez les quatre c'est
champagne ce soir alors très simplement
la blog shane ça commence en 2009
quand satoshi nakamoto un alias anonyme
dont on connaîtra jamais l'identité
décide de créer un système de cash en
ligne qui ne dépend d'aucune monnaie
d'état et pour ça il crée le bitcoin qui
est sulfureux et dont tout le monde
parle pour faire marcher le bitcoin il a
besoin d'une base de données qui est
robuste qui n'apportent pas de point
d'origine puisque elle ne dépend
d'aucune autorité d'aucun état et il
crée la blocs chaîne qui en soi est un
système où tout un chacun vous comme moi
comme tout le monde peut mettre sa
puissance de calcul son ordinateur au
service de la blocs chaîne et sécuriser
les transactions en allouant cette
puissance de calcul et c'est comme ça
que la bio tchané
alors vous n'y comprenez rien et moi non
plus des fois mais en fait il ya un seul
fait que je veux que vous compreniez
c'est que ça fait dix ans que la blog
chaîne existe on l'a attaquée par tous
les bouts depuis dix ans et on ne l'a
jamais mis en défaut et c'est pour ça
qu'on peut lui faire confiance et ça
c'est important
pourquoi parce qu'en fait la façon dont
une après dont on appréhende une
technologie ce n'est pas par la
compréhension d'une technologie mais par
la confiance qu'on en a je vous illustre
un peu le fait très simplement quand je
suis dans une voiture moi je comprends
très bien quand je tourne le volant vers
la droite
les roues tournent vers la droite et ma
voiture tourne vers la droite
sache qu'on prend la même façon je
comprends très bien comment google
marche c'est à dire qu'il a indexé tous
les sites du monde entier
il leur a donné une note unique à chacun
et ils compliquent suffit l'algorithme
d'année en année sur différents critères
pour avoir un bon ranking de sites est
le premier site que vous voyez est censé
être le plus pertinent
voilà comment ça marche par contre quand
j'envoie des mails je ne comprend
absolument rien aux normes le peuple
imap ce genre de choses je ne comprends
rien pour moi la compréhension des mails
elle est à peu près équivalente à sa
voix là et pourtant j'en envoie 30 à 40
par jour et tout va bien pourquoi parce
que j'ai confiance
de la même façon on peut l'enlever
de la même façon quand je monte dans un
avion je comprends très bien comment ça
marche
je comprends très bien quel est le lien
entre les ailes de l'avion le vent et
que ça va tirer l'avion vers le haut et
pourtant mon état mental
quand je monte dans l'avion il est comme
ça je me sens vraiment pas bien pourquoi
parce que il ya un pilote
merci et donc en fait tout ça c'est une
question de confiance sur les techno
c'est à dire qu'en fait quand vous
utilisez une technologie vous n'êtes pas
obligé de la comprendre et d'ailleurs
dans la majorité des cas vous ne la
comprenais pas par contre vous lui
faites confiance et vous utilisez une
nouvelle technologie quand il y a plus
en plus de personnes autour de vous qui
l'utilisent
quand vous avez le plus de témoignages
favorables autour de vous qui
l'utilisent ou quand vous avez
simplement pas le choix parce que votre
société vous l'imposent ou parce que les
process font ce qu'ils font et c'est ça
le principe de l'adoption de la
technologie
donc le vrai problème ce n'est pas de
comprendre comment marche le blog chaîne
mais pourquoi on est en train de mettre
en place des blocs shane et quelle est
la confiance qu'on a sur les systèmes
analogues
alors la confiance si vous voulez on
peut l'illustrer très facilement on a
tous un souvenir tous chacun individuel
mais qui revient pour tout le monde a la
même chose
c'est le jour où
vos parents ou enlever les petites roues
du vélo et que vous avez avancé
vous saviez pas du tout comment vous
alliez tenir mais vous aviez confiance
dans vos parents et vous avez avancé
vous avez fait vingt mètres et après
vous êtes tombé parce que voilà on tombe
toujours la première fois mais vous y
êtes allé parce que vous aviez confiance
et aujourd'hui si on prend un système
analogue à la blocs chaîne dans lequel
vous évoluez tous le système par exemple
économique la confiance on va la résumer
très très simplement dans le système
économique la confiance c'est la
différence entre deux objets assez
facile et qu'on connaît tous ces deux
objets là alors pour ceux qui sont loin
je vais illustrer alors à ma gauche on a
un dollar on connaît le dollar
à ma droite on a 100 bolivar vénézuélien
la différence entre les deux c'est la
confiance
c'est à dire que un dollar on sait ce
que ça vaut le monde est indexé sur le
dollar
tout va bien sans bolivar vénézuélien
ça ne vaut plus rien ça vaut tellement
rien que pour vous illustrer la valeur
d'un bolivar vénézuélien
je vais vous montrer ça là on a des
vénézuéliens qui sont pas bêtes que tout
que tout le monde
ils ont trouvé une nouvelle utilisation
alors monnaie et ouais on en est à la
sur un système et ça ça vous explique
bien qu'un système en crise
ça peut très vite basculer sur des
systèmes classiques dire que si je
reprends mon portefeuille aujourd'hui
qui est un peu l'expression de ma vie
dans mon portefeuille j'ai des cartes
bleues qui me permettent de payer
j'ai aussi du cash alors c'est des vrais
faux billets et j'ai ma carte d'identité
qu'elle a lors d'une crise financière
économique enfin là qu'est ce qui se
passe
en fait lors d'une crise financière au
départ c'est l'économie qui vacille
ensuite c'est la banque et les
distributeurs de billets donc vous
pouvez plus toucher à votre carte
d'identité je l'éteins et ensuite j'ai
parfois envie d'avoir le problème avec
le système incendie et ensuite à la fin
si on n'arrête pas une crise en fait
c'est l'état qui va même faire des
faïences et votre identité vos preuves
de résidence etc elles n'existeront plus
il s'est illustré bien un vrai problème
de nos systèmes actuels c'est que nos
systèmes actuellement n'ont jamais été
aussi fragile
il ne suffit que d'une pichenette à
l'heure actuelle pour faire basculer un
système ils ont des organismes de
contrôle qui ont peu d'autorité peu de
pouvoir et donc peu de puissance pour se
réguler et ça c'est un vrai vrai
problème on va faire un petit sondage
parce que sur ce niveau là on se sent
tous impuissants au niveau individuel on
se sent tous impuissants face aux crises
qu'on va devoir résoudre dans les années
prochaines
les crises sanitaires les crises
climatique les crises économiques
on se rend bien compte
qu'individuellement on n'arrivera pas à
être la solution
il n'y aura pas de héros pour nous
sauver pourquoi pourquoi on n'a pas ce
pouvoir ce pouvoir on ne l'a pas parce
qu'on sait déresponsabiliser on n'a plus
les responsabilités de notre pouvoir
on va faire un sondage interactif très
rapide parmi vous levez vous tous ceux
qui pensent qu'il faut réduire nos et
nous les gaz à effet de serre et qui
pensent que voilà c'est un vrai enjeu
il faut y aller lever vous tous
s'enlever vous tous ceux qui le pensent
vous avez levé la main aussi voilà
rester debout rester tous debout
maintenant parmi tous ceux qui sont
debout qui a un compte dans une banque
française
vous restez debout les autres vous
pouvez vous asseoir tout le monde
troisième étape il est 18 heures je
pense qu'il ya des banques qui sont
encore ouvertes
changer de banque changer de banque tout
de suite asseyez-vous savoure
essayez-vous alors changer de banque
pour une simple et bonne raison c'est
que aujourd'hui et quand on regarde les
stats sur les banques
aujourd'hui la france c'est un pour cent
des gaz à effet de serre dans le monde
les banques françaises ces 4,5 pour cent
on a des systèmes qui consomme plus que
nous aujourd'hui 1000 euros dans un
compte en banque qui ne bouge pas qui ne
bouge pas c'est une tonne de co2
générées
c'est une voiture qui circule toute
l'année impressionnant non
alors comment on fait parce qu'en fait
l'argent qui est sur votre compte
aujourd'hui il ya une suspension
d'incrédulité la suspension
d'incrédulité au cinéma c'est quand vous
allez voir le cinquième élément et que
vous voyez des taxis qui volent et vous
êtes dans un monde où les taxis vol
c'est cohérent vous croyez que dans ce
monde les taxis vole bien y'a pas de
problème vous revenez dans la vie réelle
les taxis ne vole pas mieux vous avez à
adhérer au message vous avez adhéré à
l'univers aujourd'hui vous adhérez à un
univers où vous vous dites que les 1000
euros par exemple qui sont sur votre
compte sur votre solde sont dans une
petite boîte à votre nom et y bouge pas
et la réalité elle est différente c'est
qu'en fait c'est 1000 euros ils sont
investis dans des projets qui sont
décidées par la banque au dessus et ses
projets à 70%
c'est des centrales à charbon c'est des
sables bitumineux c'est des projets qui
sont a vraiment des projets dans des
valeurs auxquelles vous adhérez donc
qu'est ce qu'on fait maintenant
parce qu'on a plus de responsabilités
donc on n'a plus de pouvoir et c'est ça
l'objectif de la bloquer en blog shane
on décentralise pour récupérer nos
responsabilités pour ensuite créer des
systèmes de finances décentralisée parce
que dès qu'il ya un centre il ya des
décisions qui ne vous conviennent pas
nous on crée des systèmes qui sont plus
robustes plus flexible et qui permettent
de créer en fait des banques sur mesure
à l'échelle des individus
ça demande un petit travail individuel
de chacun donc de comprendre quelles
sont ses valeurs et quels sont les
points sur lesquels ils veulent appuyer
mais je suis désolé de vous le dire mais
si on veut résoudre tous les problèmes
aujourd'hui il va falloir qu'on se
responsabilisent
parce que si vous voulez on connaît tous
la maxime dans spider-man de l'oncle ben
qui dit qu'un grand pouvoir implique de
grandes responsabilités mais on a oublié
que le monde dans lequel cette maxime
est dit c'est un monde où des
super-héros émergent
il n'y a pas de super héros dans notre
monde actuellement et il n'y en aura pas
en fait la maximale est inverse dans
notre monde c'est des responsabilités
apporte du pouvoir et donc vous avez
besoin de plusieurs éléments
si on reprend un peu les liens logiques
que je vous ai dit en fait tout le jeu
il est simple on reprend nos
responsabilités pourraient avoir du
pouvoir pour ensuite comprendre un
système et lui faire confiance pourquoi
parce que c'est nous les mettre à mort
aujourd'hui vous vous devez être les
capitaines de votre propre navire est la
seule confiance qu'on peut avoir c'est
la confiance que ici au sein de toute
cette salle on va tous faire des bonnes
choses
ou en tout cas que les actions mauvaise
ou être compensée par les bonnes actions
et qu'on arrivera à un équilibre
quand on met un centre on a plus d'
équilibre
quand on met un centre on est assujettie
à des volontés voilà j'ai à peu près
expliquer tout ce qui devait s'expliquer
sur la blogo chain même si vous n'avez
pas forcément compris exactement comment
ça marchait minute par minute dans ce
monde en temps réel vous comprenez quels
sont les enjeux et le pourquoi du
comment
j'ai une dernière chose à vous dire et
ce principe il est sur la confiance
on a parlé de confiance dans les
systèmes on a parlé de confiance dans
les technologies on a parlé de confiance
dans l'innovation et on n'a pas parlé du
plus important c'est la confiance en
vous en fait aujourd'hui vous devez
avoir confiance en vous personne ne le
fera à votre place vous devez avoir
confiance en vous parce que vous allez
devoir faire des pas vers l'avant et
n'est pas vers l'avant si vous n'avez
pas confiance en vous ce sont des gadins
par contre si vous avez confiance en
vous que vous ratiez ou pas vous aurez
avancé voilà merci
[Applaudissements]